[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's seven o'clock welcome to this Sky
News special program live from Dover
during the next 60 minutes we'll have
reaction and Analysis after the deaths
of at least four people trying to cross
the English Channel on a small
inflatable boat
more than 40 people survived the ordeal
dragged to Safety in freezing conditions
one fisherman telling Sky News his
vessel was surrounded by people
screaming for help
it's not important across the channel
and of too much in about 45 people in
one dinky I'm not surprised that they
pull over there they think he collapsed
there's too much people in it
rescue teams were quick to respond to
the British and French navies Coast
Guard helicopters and lifeboats all
involved in the search for survivors
I'm in Ashford at a hospital that
treated some of those who were emergency
departments across Kent were told to
expect multiple casualties
the government says it wants migrants to
take safe legal routes to get to the UK
but for some people that seems
impossible today here in France we've
met people determined to get to Britain
any way they can
also heads we'll hear from one man who
survived a previous Crossing who says it
was the cruel channel that killed the
victims today
and the huge increase in people risking
the crossing and the resource is needed
when they get into trouble
[Music]
hello there and good evening from Dover
it is another deadly reminder of the
risks people are willing to run to enter
the United Kingdom at least four people
dead and 43 more rescued attempting to
make the dangerous journey across the
channel in a small inflatable boat one
migrant who managed to get to Britain
last year told us that the channel was
cruel and at every second those Crossing
it feel like they are at risk
well tonight we'll hear from our
correspondent in France where the small
boat set off and in Ashford where one
person lost their life following the
ordeal but first let's take a look at
how it all unfolded
well the incident happened around
halfway between the Kent coast and the
coast of France Sky News understands the
boat set off from amble to's Beach just
Southwest of Calais the alarm was raised
just after three o'clock this morning
to Search and Rescue helicopters plus a
french navy helicopter are an ally
lifeboats and other UK and French Navy
boats were all involved in the rescue
our home editor Jason Farrell has
tonight's first report on this morning's
rescue operation and a warning it does
include pictures of the dead body of one
of the victims
death trap in the English Channel
the dinghy bottom has collapsed the
people inside are immersed in freezing
water their lives in the balance
salvation is a hundred foot scallop boat
called Arcturus every face is focused on
the rope that could save them if they
can just reach it
photos capture the horror people up to
their necks in water the man in blue at
the back barely hanging on
some had left away from the dean
screaming for help
and see in the bottom right corner of
this shot two people hardly able to keep
their heads above water
a fisherman Raymond was among those
rescuing the migrants and he spoke
exclusively to us from his boat on the
phone
if she was calm we finished still was
very heavy
[Music]
for all these people have all screaming
they didn't feel real it was just 40
years everywhere all around the boards
five six people each say we were outside
to get a border board profession here
and tell them a crew don't let me go
please help
the Royal Navy french navy Coast Guard
and rnli lifeboats helped in ensuring
the last survivors were plucked from the
sea Guided by helicopter spotlights
above it's rare that a rescue is
documented in this detail and the Grim
reality is also captured by the
fisherman's camera showing that not
everyone made it
this man had attached himself to the
side of Raymond's boat out of sight
until it was too late
you can almost feel the ice cold
temperatures of just one degree Celsius
just looking at the images of those who
made it on board okay
fully increase the body heat slowly if
you do it too quickly it could be a
heart attack after Raymond and his crew
had pulled the people out of the water
and given them a warm shower and warm
clothes they realized they had 31 people
on board and what's clear now is that if
Ray's Boat hadn't been in the right
place at the right time many if not all
of those people would have died in the
water
it's not important to cross the channel
and I'm not surprised that they think he
collapsed there's too much people in it
but those warnings and these images
don't seem to deter nearly 45
000 people have crossed the channel this
year and many more will try
Jason Farrell Sky News Dover
well our national correspondent Tom
Parmenter is here with me now in Dover
Tom just watching that footage it's it's
harrowing and it's terrifying isn't it
you know you wouldn't last long in the
water in these sort of temperatures
um is there still a search operation
underway well of course we have to say
that it's expected potentially that
there could be further victims because
there is never a list on these boats of
people who were on board and they have
to go by the accounts that people can
give them who were rescued it was a
great slice of Fortune the the one
Slither of good luck in all this was
that that fishing vessel was so close to
be able to pick up the people who were
in the water and as you say biting the
cold again here tonight as it was
yesterday and the search and Recovery
operation as it will be now is purely
just trying to establish whether or not
there was anyone else in the water
finding them alive now is simply not
going to happen it is yet another
Dreadful example of the risks that
people are prepared to take of course
facilitated by these gangs of criminals
operating on the coast of northern
France up to five thousand pounds those
people had paid for a space in that
overcrowded boat and of course it comes
one day after Rishi sunak the British
prime minister outlined his vision to
get a grip on this crisis that we've
just seen escalating over the last
couple of years more and more people but
these incidents do not deter them the
efforts of the British and the French
governments do not deter them and this
bitingly cold weather here tonight that
we've seen this week does not deter them
there will be other people on the
northern coast of France tonight
expecting to
hand over their money and take their
chances yet again yeah incredible Tom I
know you're going to stick around we'll
speak to you a bit later on in the
program but let's cross over to our your
correspondent Adam Parsons on the other
side of the channel he's in sangat and
Adam just listening to what Tom was
saying uh there it seems incredible
doesn't it given what has happened today
that tonight there will be people where
you are considering making this very
same Journey
absolutely I mean songat is a a name
that is synonymous with these sort of
Crossings I can't imagine how many of
these small boats have set off uh from
the beach behind me to try to get to
Britain it is temptingly close when you
stand here in a clear day you can see
over uh to the White Cliffs but of
course that forgets the fact that that
English channel is the busiest shipping
Lane in the world it is Inky dark in the
water around there there are large ships
passing and it is freezing cold at this
time of uh yeah if you've thought about
this logically you wouldn't do it but
everybody who is here every migrant who
comes to this corner of France comes
here for only one reason and that is to
try to get over to Britain and the vast
majority are trying to do so in these
these dinghies and these small boats a
year ago
uh almost to the day I was here after it
turned out 31 people had died in making
one of these Journeys and at the time
there was so much political rhetoric
talking about action that had to be
taken an action has been talked about
but we haven't seen much in the way of
concrete movement instead we've seen
Rising numbers and tonight more debt as
this continuing tide of Small Boat
Crossings
these migrant camps are the last stop
for people planning to get to Britain
the deals are done here between people
Smugglers who have boats and migrants
willing to pay thousands of pounds for a
place on board and overloaded dinghy
we met these men Indians from Punjab
last night they were also out in the
channel their boat started sinking five
kilometers from the French Coast
you went back to France you came to the
beach again on your boat yes we again
again beat Dan jump and swimming then
swimming yeah very cold water wow you
had to swim yeah back to the beach yeah
you are lucky to be alive I killed last
night
you die you think you died right yeah
you are lucky that you are here yeah
it is a complex problem look at this
last month we filmed migrants running
past French policing clambering into
boats held offshore by people Smugglers
the French officers are under orders not
to enter the water
so if you get past them then they can't
stop you
and this year a record number of
migrants have taken to small boats
the channel today was deadly cold
what's remarkable is not that people
died here but that sent off in flimsy
ding is more people haven't perished in
these waters before
both the French and British say they
will do more to combat this sort of
cross-channel migration
with this rescue and Recovery operation
started in the small hours and it's been
going on all day ever since it involves
both British and French resources now
this French boat has only just been
assigned to work full time here in the
English Channel a sign of a greater
focus by France on cross-channel
migration
while we were out another sign at the
heightened tension
you know
coordinating
the British Coast Guard issuing an alert
after reports of more people in the
water
but so far nothing has stemmed the tide
more people arrive or try to cross
despite the peril more deaths feel
inevitable
I'm sure that what we will see now is an
uptick in the political rhetoric and
that people will once again say
something has to be done the trouble is
it's hard to know what is going to be
done this is an enormously complex
question it's not simply about stopping
people getting across that water it's
about questioning why they're trying to
make that Journey anyway how can you
prevent them how can you scrutinize them
how can you act within international law
an example of that very clearly is the
British government talks about illegal
migration the United Nations insists
that it cannot be illegal to claim
Asylum and that if a person chooses to
claim asylum in Britain then that is
their right British government responds
by saying well they should be taking a
legal route and others will say unless
you come from from Afghanistan or Syria
or Hong Kong or Ukraine it's almost
impossible to get into Britain to claim
Asylum legally and it is the this
gordian knot of questions that has to be
somehow unpicked yes there's been an
increase in funding for the French
police yes there has certainly been an
upsurge in political rhetoric on both
sides of the channel but have we seen
any concrete action to stop these sort
of accidents frankly I think the answer
to that is no
well a number of those who were on the
boat in the early hours of this morning
have been treated in hospitals in Kent
Skies saja choudhary is at the William
Harvey Hospital in Ashford Saudia have
you had an update on their condition
yes well two of the people that were
rescued were brought to this Hospital in
Ashford that's about a 40-minute drive
from Dungeness on the south coast much
quicker of course by air ambulance now
this morning East Kent hospitals was put
on standby so emergency departments
across Kent were told to expect multiple
casualties and they remained on standby
until about nine this morning and in
that time two of those people that were
rescued were brought to William Harvey
hospital here in Ashford and this
afternoon the hospital confirmed to Sky
News that sadly one of them had died
they are included in the overall four
people to have lost their lives during
this incident and the other patient was
treated here and as of around 4 30 this
afternoon which is when the hospital
last updated us that person was due to
be discharged today
um now we don't know their identities we
don't know if they're men or women or
adults or children because of course the
next of kin have to be informed and that
in itself is a difficult task to undergo
because a lot of these people that come
from France to the UK on these small
boats often do so without any official
documentation so no passports or birth
certificates and many of them don't
speak English or speak very little
English so it's very difficult for them
to communicate with Medics and those
Refugee support workers tonight there's
a warning from the British red crosses
director of refugee support work who
Alex Frazier who says that that the fact
that people take this journey in these
temperatures shows how desperate they
are and that people don't risk their
lives like this unless they have run out
of all options and he said that unless
there are more accessible and safe
routes to claim asylum in the UK he
warned that there is a danger we will
continue to see incidents like this in
the future
thank you
and Adam in sangatin northern France uh
thank you both for now well residents
and Charities here in Kent are well used
of course to dealing with migrants
arriving from France today they are
faced with another Journey that ended in
tragedy the Home Secretary swella
bravaman expressed her profound sadness
and called the incident a sobering
reminder of why the government has to
end these Crossings
our communities correspondent Lisa
Holland reports now on the UK's response
to the crisis
Ali is an asylum Seeker from Iran who
crossed the channel on a small boat last
year he says it was a terrifying
experience
every second every moment we are
expecting a bad happening a bad incident
because you are like a like a small
Point small dot at the middle of nowhere
with all of big fairies big
cargo ship ships and stuff so we were so
scared
when you heard the news
what had happened to the people on the
channel what went through your mind they
have lots of hopes lots of plan for rest
of their life and the cruel Channel
killed them
it's not the first time Ali is mourning
the deaths of fellow Asylum Seekers he
was friends with five members of the
Kurdish Iranian nejad family who
perished in the channel two years ago
the mother of family sent me uh sent me
a voice message and told me all of the
smokers
are so bad people and they were thinking
they are thinking about money only money
not Humanity
the government is clear about who's to
blame
crossing the channel in unseaworthy
vessels is a lethally dangerous endeavor
it is for this reason above all that we
are working so hard to destroy the
business model of the people Smugglers
evil organized criminals who treat human
beings as cargo
that campaigners say Boat Crossings are
being driven by the lack of safe and
legal routes for genuine Asylum Seekers
to reach the UK
it is simply not possible in most
circumstances for someone fleeing
persecution or a war-torn country to
wait for a fictitious scheme which may
or may not come in time to sometimes
save their lives or the lives of their
families or loved ones it is not a
compassionate approach
those who've made it to the UK say
people understand how dangerous the
journey is but it won't stop them from
Crossing Lisa Holland Sky News
well let's bring in our chief political
correspondent John Craig who's in
Westminster Forest this evening and John
there's a terrible irony isn't there
here that yesterday the Prime Minister
was outlying his plan to deal with this
problem and yet today we see another
tragedy
yes and the statement made by the PM
yesterday was referred to several times
by Suella bravman today his five point
plan that Mr sunac began prime
minister's questions today by talking
about his sorrow and what had happened
overnight and that was echoed by other
party leaders secure starmer and Ed
Davey of the liberal democrats for
example but it's only a few weeks since
uh Suella bravam and was talking about a
Invasion on the on the south coast uh
comments that uh that earned her a
rebuke from the Archbishop of Canterbury
no less her tone today was much more
measured there was quite a somber tone
throughout all the exchanges in the
House of Commons I mean she for example
was saying these are the days that we
dread and she reformed also the fact
that around about a year ago 27 people
on one day lost their lives so it's a
sobering reminder of why we have to end
these Crossings she said now
in response to that the uh there was for
example
um claims by wanta Tory MP from Kent
that's uh
um Greg McKinley a groundhog day he said
and yet Roger Gale uh sir Roger Gale
another thanat mp on Sky News was
talking about the government playing to
the right wing gallery and accused them
of a lack of compassion now there was
also towards the end of the exchanges uh
Jeremy corbyn the former labor leader
was talking about holding out the hand
of humanity and friendship uh to very
desperate people and that and him a
rebuke from Sue Ella bravaman when she
said we need a reality check here the
reality is not everybody getting on a
small boat or unseaworthy vessel is a
refugee and not everyone coming here
illegally is here on humanitarian
grounds the economic immigrants coming
illegally she said now also highly
significantly immediately after uh
swella braven's statements and all the
questions a Tori MP Jonathan gullus
moved a bill Asylum seeker's removal to
Safe countries built now a private
members Bill the aim being to send the
Asylum Seekers back to off to Rwanda as
the government has talked about with and
ignore any legal rulings that might come
from either courts here or in Europe
that failed by uh 188 votes to 69 but
highly significantly 69 right-wing
Tories backed that enough to defeat the
irishi sunak a big Rebellion if that
were to come to a big vote in the
Commons so more evidence that the prime
minister is under huge pressure from the
right wing of his party to tackle this
issue and that's perhaps where we've
heard so much in the last 24 hours and
although today's uh statement by the
Home Secretary obviously who followed
the tragedy overnight
John May
not many day in Westminster shall we
we're joined Now by David Simmons chair
of the all party parliamentary group on
migration uh thank you for your time
this evening interesting hearing John
Craig there talk about that boat that
sank almost a year ago 27 people
perishing in the channel why has nothing
happened since then
clearly a lot has happened since then I
mean the government made some statements
about the very large numbers of people
who have been resettled to the UK from
places like Hong Kong Afghanistan Syria
by sacred legal routes and I was very
pleased to hear that the Home Secretary
has been working very actively with the
authorities in the EU in France in
Belgium other countries that are
involved on getting in place and fixes
but I think the strength of feeling
that's been expressed in the last couple
of days demonstrates that it's not about
any particular political party or any
wing of any political party everyone
wants to find a way to stop this from
happening we want to make sure that
people have access to safe and legal
routes who have a genuine and legitimate
claim to Asylum and refuge in the United
Kingdom and that we have a more
effective way of deterring people who
don't have such a genuine claim from
putting their lives at risk
you mentioned safe and legal routes
there Ukraine some from Syria
Afghanistan
Etc but there are many countries around
the world where people are struggling
where they do need to flee tyranny and
there isn't a safe route for them why is
it taking so long for that to happen
this is exactly the point that I raised
during the debate and in questions
earlier on today we need to ensure that
people who for example are in northern
France who have family members in the UK
perhaps parents close relations who
would have a genuine claim and we know
that for those who come from Iran for
example around 98 will have their Asylum
claim in the UK approved have a means to
make that application in Britain safely
at the moment you cannot apply for
asylum in Britain unless you are
physically here and that's why people
are putting their hands in their lives
their lives in the hands of the people
Smugglers so we need to change that
situation we need a means for people to
make that application so we can consider
it properly in the UK and give them
permission to travel here if they have a
good claim at the same time as breaking
the business model the people Smugglers
which depends entirely on the absence of
any safe route by which people could
come to the UK who have a genuine claim
the Prime Minister uh made his
announcement yesterday do you feel that
what he had to say goes far enough many
people say that they don't think those
ideas were bold enough
it's a huge step in the right direction
I think we made more progress in that
statement than we have certainly in the
last few years in addressing the issue
and prioritizing people who come to the
UK from countries that we know are safe
like Albania which has been on the UK
home offices safe list for more than a
decade we'll go a long way towards
dealing with the backlog of Asylum
applications and making sure that
genuine Asylum Seekers get their right
to a place towards the head of the queue
but clearly we need to go further and
the work that the Home Secretary is
doing in particular with their French
authorities is the thing that will
really begin to fix this and the next
step needs to be looking at what is the
means by which people who have a genuine
claim can make that claim safely without
having to put their hands their lives in
the hands of people Smugglers that is
the thing that will crack that business
model and make sure that the UK has the
kind of Asylum system that we all want
to see
is focusing on more deterrence though
the right way to go about this because
surely that will push people to more and
more Desperate Measures to to cross over
from France for example we managed to
stop people largely coming on lorries
that was successful but what they now do
is come on boats which is even more
dangerous
yeah I entirely agree with you
deterrence is a part of this but that's
about people knowing that in the UK we
have an asylum system which is robust is
safe and that if they have a genuine
claim then they'll be treated favorably
if they don't have a genuine claim then
they can expect to be returned to their
country of origin or to another safe
country so policies like the Rwanda
policy announced last year will be a
small part of that but it's absolutely
clear under our laws if people have a
legitimate claim in this country they
need to be able to come and make it
safely and if they don't they need to be
dealt with by robust border controls and
it's getting that balance right is the
thing that will make sure we don't see
any more people losing their lives in
the channel in this awful way
why do people want to come here why do
they want to risk their lives crossing
the channel when they may well travel
through plenty of other safe countries
that they could uh claim asylum in
many of the people who are coming across
the channel are doing so because they
have connections to the UK typically
family members who are already here they
might have a husband a wife they might
have parents or children who are already
in the United Kingdom and they want to
join them and that's one of the reasons
why they would have a well-founded claim
to come to to the UK the European Union
has a policy called the Dublin treaty
which means that you're required inside
the EU to make your Asylum claim in the
first safe country and that means many
of the people and I met a lot of them
personally in Calais earlier in the year
are not able to claim asylum in France
or anywhere else in the European Union
and therefore the United Kingdom is the
only country that remains that they can
go to but we need to recognize the UK is
not a particularly popular destination
for Asylum Seekers more than double the
numbers go to France more than three
times the numbers go to Germany it tends
to be those people who have a connection
to Britain that want to come here and we
need to recognize that in the way that
our Asylum system operates
this country of course as you well know
has a very proud history of opening its
arms to people who are in need whether
it's those suffering in Ukraine at the
moment or you go back to World War II
even beyond that do you think this
government is being compassionate enough
my constituency is home to generations
of people who've come to the UK and
found sanctuous refugees and I think the
fact that we resettle very large numbers
of peoples from country countries across
the world that were real trouble spots
demonstrates that we're willing to do
that this is an issue about making sure
that people who are not part of
resettlement schemes from places like
Syria Ukraine or Afghanistan but who are
choosing to come to the UK because they
have a connection here have a safe and
legal route to do so so that we can make
a proper decision in a safe way about
the legitimacy of their claim and that's
why we need to have safer and legal
routes in place so that the UK
government can make a fair and best
decision about the validity of their
claim and people are not tempted to put
their lives at risk making Channel
Crossings like this
it needs to happen quickly though
doesn't it I've been coming down here
for the last five or six years reporting
on these boats coming across the channel
and yet we're still in this situation
why isn't it happening quicker
it does need to happen quickly and I
know the international Asylum system is
probably under an unprecedented degree
of pressure there's more than 100
million people displaced in the world at
the moment who are looking for somewhere
that they can seek Refuge but clearly we
know there's been a high degree of
public concern about this we need to
recognize that governments of all
parties have sought to balance the needs
of the country and the desired people to
seek Asylum here but in my view given
that the large numbers of people who
have a legitimate claim to Asylum in the
UK and have a direct connection here
which would would make them someone
naturally who we would find a home for
that they have a safe and legal route by
which they can do that that uh in my
view is the compassionate route and it
sits alongside the kinds of resettlement
schemes where the UK has done a great
deal more in most cases than any other
country for example in Europe
okay we must leave it there uh David
Simmons thank you very much chair the
all party parliamentary group on
migration we appreciate your time
if you're watching a Sky News special
program live from Dover coming up after
the break we'll be discussing in detail
what can be done to prevent a repeat of
today's tragic loss of life in the
channel
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello again welcome back to Dover where
in the early hours of this morning a
huge rescue operation was launched after
a boat carrying migrants capsized in the
middle of the channel four people died
43 were mercifully rescued several of
those are said to be fighting for their
lives in hospital
well joining me now is severe zazai
chair of the Scottish Refugee Council a
refugee from Afghanistan also Susan
fratzke senior policy Analyst at the
migration policy Institute and Kevin
Saunders as well former Chief
immigration officer for UK border force
in Calais uh very good to see you all
this evening thank you very much for
your time on what has been a very
difficult day for many people in this
part of the world as they try and
grapple with what is a a seriously
difficult problem to get to the bottom
of and severe props I can come to you
first what went through your mind when
you woke up this morning and heard this
news given your history and personal
experience
hey Jonathan well um he was a default
experience for me to be frank because
this is just that week about 32 years 23
years ago this week I arrived in the
back of a lorry in Dover and I could
have been one of those people and uh is
is sad that 23 years on we still have uh
a process or a route that is costing
lives every unavoidable debt is a
tragedy our thoughts and my thoughts are
with the family friends of those who
have sadly lost their lives and those
that have been impacted and I pay
tribute to The Rescuers who have dealt
with this horrendous uh incident
um from my own experience I'd say no one
risks their own or their family's life
unless they are running from dangers
more acute than those they face on these
dangerous Journeys
and sabir I'll ask you the same question
that I asked our previous guest um why
is it that they feel the need to come to
to this country why risk your life
Crossing this treacherous stretch of
water when you could perhaps make a life
for yourself in another of European
Europe's countries where you would be
safe you can claim Asylum there why risk
your life to get here there's a range of
reasons I don't want to repeat what uh
uh Mr
Simmons said
I think uh yeah families one key aspect
where people have family so if for
example my family's life and my father's
life was at risk in Afghanistan uh he's
not they're not my family is not
entitled to the schemes that are
provided for Afghanistan and if they
want to flee the Taliban regime they
would to be with me and that family
support and connection is very important
we also need to acknowledge the fact
that UK has got uh a recognition uh and
a reputation for human rights around the
world and people do see the UK as a
place of safety and the other aspect is
also the English language and um some
people might speak English language
people don't want to just move and uh
and and and end up in a in a limbo they
want to rebuild their lives and they
want to contribute and be a positive and
a part of that Society so that also
attracts people to come to the UK
because maybe that journey of
integration is a lot more uh easier if
you speak the language and you can
rebuild your life make a contribution
and have a a dignified uh income in life
like everyone else
Kevin Saunders Let's uh turn to you in
your former role you know this part of
the world very well you must be full of
praise for those who carried out that
rescue last night
oh a fantastic operation by the
emergency services to get out there so
quickly and to deal with it and to the
the fishing boat it was first on the
scene and by all accountants has done a
fantastic job in rescuing a large number
of people it was bitterly cold last
night and having seen the pictures some
of the people on the boat are in
t-shirts and
um very flimsy life jackets so the the
the fisherman did a great job well done
to them
and Kevin what do you see as the
solution to this crisis and do you feel
we are working now better with the
French than we have in the past
yes we're working much better with the
French I mean we always when I was in
France we always had a very very good
relationship with the French at
operational level we worked extremely
well together we did joint exercises
together
uh we we worked very very well
unfortunately the politicians uh perhaps
didn't get on quite so well but now they
seem to have got over that and so Ella
bryman's been speaking with the French
minister of the interior and they seem
to be getting on famously so it looks
much more promising
um with our political relations with
French
Susan fratsky you've worked um in this
area for for a long time
um studied it extensively when you heard
what the Prime Minister had to say
yesterday he's putting this firmly on
his own shoulders sorting out this
crisis he mentioned a number of ideas a
number of proposals that he's putting
forward to try and reduce the number of
boats coming across is he going about
things in the right way
sure so there's two I think main pieces
of the proposals that have been put to
put forward the first part is really a
set of measures that are focused on
enforcement counter smuggling and with
regard to those proposals I think
um it's smuggling is one thing and
counter smuggling and enforcement is
something that it's quite easy to talk
about but hard to do in practice this is
something that policy makers and
governments tend to come back to when
they don't actually know what else to do
so this is a main point that's been
raised for example in the the European
Union often in trying to address the the
crisis in the Mediterranean no one is is
really going to come to the defense of
Smugglers or traffickers but the
challenge is that this doesn't really
address the complex drivers or
motivations of people who are moving and
it doesn't necessarily address the
challenges that Asylum systems face in
then actually dealing with the the cases
and situations of people who arrive so
the second set of of measures that's
been outlined is trying to begin to
address some of these Asylum pressures
and address backlogs and speeding up
processing which is all very good and
important and something that we really
need to sort out the operations of our
Asylum systems but it's really in a
question of how you actually do it and
it needs to be done in a way that
actually maintains The credibility and
integrity of the process both in terms
of the quality of decisions Asylum
decisions that are actually being given
to those who are arriving from a human
perspective but also from maintaining
the the Integrity of the system
perspective if you have bad decisions
these lead to appeals and then tend to
to continue to create pressures on the
systems so the the Prime Minister has
suggested a couple of different things
to address these pressures one is
scaling up Staffing which is helpful but
also it's important to keep in mind that
individual people and caseworkers aren't
interchangeable and it's important to
look at actually the training of who's
being hired how they're being prepared
this is is really a long-term measure
and secondly how procedures are being
done so he's proposed some changes to
streamlining simplifying procedures
dropping interviews at different at
different places which is incredibly
important and an important tool but
again the devil is is in the details so
which cases are being sped up which
interviews are being dropped how these
are actually then affecting the the um
the individuals and their ability to
make a really good faith claim for
Asylum and finally it's important to
note that addressing backlogs and this
this huge crunch of cases that's built
up through the system over years isn't
just about speeding up new decisions but
figuring out how to address Legacy cases
and that requires specific resources and
modalities so I think with regard to
addressing the the pressures on the
Asylum system specifically these are
important steps but it's going to come
down to I think a longer term gain and
how all of these measures are
implemented and resourced and thought
through in practice
yeah let's talk about that backlog with
uh severe because uh it is a real
problem isn't it and you have many
people here waiting for their claims to
be processed waiting many months and
just thinking about something you said
earlier that many of those who come here
do want to integrate do want to
contribute do want to start work but of
course at the moment they're they're not
able to
yes Jonathan I think that's where we
Source some degree of honesty from the
Prime Minister yesterday
and that was the recognition of the
after administration of the UK's Asylum
system there is a backlog of nearly 150
000 people waiting on an initial
decision of their Asylum claim which
impacts obviously hugely on people's
mental health well-being and in his own
words
um as the Prime Minister said it is
unfair and appalling that we are
spending 5.5 million every day on using
hotels to house Asylum Seekers
um this and I think in it we need to be
very clear on this that this is not the
fault of people seeking Asylum other
European countries manage their Asylum
systems with far greater numbers than
the UK the UK system has long been
mismanaged and
um I think um yeah yesterday the Prime
Minister failed to set out any concrete
plans to expand these uh to expand safe
uh routes through resettlement programs
or an expansion in family reunion visas
for example uh a simple humanitarian
Visa would end the smuggling visas and
bring safety and order instead of acute
risks and disorder that we have been
been seeing so the UK government in in
our opinion has yet again shown it
doesn't have a workable or principle
solution to address the appalling model
of people's modeling and reducing uh
dangerous Channel Crossings of people in
search of safety and I think to be frank
it is disturbing that the prime minister
is again using the issue of Channel
Crossings with a focus not simply to
seek to stop or reduce unsafe Journeys
but seek to end their very principle of
Asylum and protection here in the UK so
I think what we are seeing is not
something new uh for over 20 years
successive governments have introduced
hugely costly deterrence policies they
do not work
okay um I just want to bring Kevin back
in for the final word um Kevin on a
freezing cold dark night here in Dover
we think about those people on the other
side of the channel considering making
this Crossing when you heard the Prime
Minister yesterday talk about this small
boats operational command bringing
different agencies together to try and
stop the boats do you think that that
will work is that something that is part
of this solution
it certainly is a big step forward
having Everything Under One Roof so to
speak is really very helpful so
um along with that giving the NCAA more
money
um and uh what have you is is a good
idea but can I just um correct your uh
one of your other guests
the Prime Minister actually said
yesterday as we tackle illegal migration
we will create more safe and legal
routes working with the UN Refugee
agency to identify those most in need so
that we haven't slammed the door on
um
Roots at all
okay um thank you for that point and
indeed thank you uh all for your uh
contribution we do appreciate it sabir
zazai Susan flatsky and also Kevin
Saunders thank you
well the number of people illegally
crossing the channel is an important
issue isn't it for many voters and
therefore a big political problem for
the government as we've been hearing but
what are the facts about how many people
are making the crossing and also where
they come from our correspondent Tom
Cheshire has been looking at the data
we all know by now just how dangerous
the channel Crossing is freezing
conditions as you can see here it is
incredibly busy this is ship tracking
data that shows every boat in the region
at the time around two in the morning
but we can show you how the rescue would
have it by filtering out the boats not
involved here you see the fishing
vessels at the start responding they're
joined by that Lifeboat which left at
240 40 minutes later that Lifeboat is
part of it and we also see a helicopter
coming out from the UK we see other
ships a royal Navy ship French Navy ship
coming from France joining that rescue
effort and more boats continue to arrive
and depart and so do more helicopters
they're doing something different
they're not flying straight to the site
they're flying what's called a parallel
track line to look for survivors
traveling up and down the area with
search legs a short distance apart to
look for people who may have drifted in
the strong currents the search operation
continues over the next few hours now
today is the worst accident since the
disaster in November last year when 27
people died that came against this
backdrop of increasing numbers you can
see the pressure ratcheting up 2019 2020
2021 but this year it has hit a
different scale nearly 45
000 people making that Journey the
government said that people should take
safe and legal routes for immigration
but I want to show you a few big numbers
just to end and 90 of those arriving in
a small boat in the last year have
claimed Asylum that's 31
891 people there's a huge backlog
processing those claims but so far
according to the home office around a
third of those applying have been given
permission to remain so if you apply the
same rate of that holes that would mean
more than 10 000 people would be granted
Asylum as a result of crossing the
channel but look at this this is the
safe and legal route this is the
statistics the number of people who are
granted Refugee status through
resettlement from June 22 21 to June
2022 slightly different time period but
more or less comparable it is a whole
lot smaller ten thousand or so versus 1
600. now this number doesn't include
region specific schemes like Afghanistan
Ukraine and Hong Kong which have taken
thousands more but aren't open to all
nationalities and it's the difference
between those two numbers between the
ten thousand and between the 1 600 which
is why so many are willing to run the
awful risks we see in the channel
fascinating seeing the numbers there in
black and white Tom Cheshire for us
you're watching Sky News coming up after
the break we'll get an update on the
latest situation following the deaths of
four people trying to cross the channel
earlier today
[Music]
from the very beginning of this big war
since March myself and many other
Ukrainian politicians were promoting one
very simple and clear narrative
a big part of Ukrainian Victory is not
just defeating Russians on Ukraine and
soil but bringing into accountability
everyone who committed war crimes in
Ukraine because without Justice based on
international law it's important to
expect peaceful and comfortable future
for this very moment it's not my wish
it's a giant Consolidated view of G7
just two days ago G7 spread its latest
communique and let me quote there can be
no impunity for war crimes and other
atrocities we will call President Putin
and those responsible to account in
accordance with international law so
it's not my wish anymore it's not the
wish of president zielinski or all other
ukrainians that's the Consolidated
understanding of the west but the
challenge is not only to bring Russian
leadership to accountability but to
bring into accountability everyone who
committed work Brands and at the moment
I can report to you that Ukrainian
officials registered more than 70
000 crimes related to racial aggression
more than 50 000 work grants has been
detected by a Ukrainian law enforcement
all that require absolutely huge efforts
from
prosecutors from experts from
investigators and definitely it's a huge
task for Ukrainian judicial system and
for Ukrainian Georges because it's
understood for today that yes top
Russian leaders will brought into
prosecution through International
tribunal Court I hope so I recently came
back from Hague and international
criminal recordings a is working
extremely hard to have a good result
with this but all these thousands of
work Brands definitely will be
considered by Ukrainian courts well Ray
they are doing this the the training of
Ukrainian and judges is extremely
important because no one in this world
has enough capabilities and enough
experience to proceed with such a huge
amount of work right
welcome back to Dover well as we were
hearing a little bit earlier in the
program a fisherman whose crew saved 31
people stranded in the English Channel
who's told Sky News he was woken in the
early hours of the morning when migrants
surrounded his boat and was screaming
for help the skipper Raymond was
speaking to our home editor Jason fowell
receivers
receivers come and finish still was very
heavy it was a really easy for August
people that were screaming
next summer it was like somewhere out of
a movie
where are you it didn't feel evil
and it was just 40s everywhere all
around the boards and a lot of screaming
five six people each says
here and tell them a crew don't let me
go please help
[Music]
nice to see
let him below the egg and then
took off her clothes and go all the way
close off the event that Luke water
Michelle it's crazy slowly increase the
body heat slowly if you do it too
quickly it could be a heart attack
it's not about you cross the channel it
there's too much people in it
that's the skipper of that fishing boat
Raymond who I think it's fair to say is
a hero
um certainly all the efforts he made to
rescue those people and and when we look
at that footage Tom
um it is uh just utterly terrifying
isn't it people there not not even
wearing more than a flimsy t-shirt and
that very thin life jacket which it
doesn't even fit properly you went out
on a boat here a month or so ago what is
it like out in the middle of the the
channel well it is something that I
think you can almost become used to
seeing these dinghies going across the
channel but even if you set off in calm
sea conditions on either side obviously
most normally the French side coming
over to England it can get very
changeable very quickly out there in the
middle and we're out on a proper fishing
vessel last month reporting on this
whole migrant Crossing story and it's
just the way that the sea can turn very
quickly and very suddenly you're in
waves that are churning up and hitting
the side of the boat and going in
different directions over a meat at all
quite quickly and you put yourself in
the position of being in one of those
inflatable boats right on the water solo
down it doesn't take much at all for
that water to come on board and for
panic to set in and I think we can
almost become a bit desensitized the
horrific position that people are
putting themselves in
it's an issue isn't it that really
divides opinion many people here are
understandably frustrated at the boats
coming over continually what do you have
to say on that tonight well this is a
national concern as well it's a most
acute here in Kent but across the
country there are a whole spectrum of
views on what this means and and the
sympathy levels and really getting an
answer for everyone on every side of
that debate is so important an answer
that works yeah okay Tom thank you very
much thank you for watching this special
program on Sky News coming up next more
from Dover
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]